[Music]
so my name is Ivan tarkoff I work for
Microsoft Research our team is called in
or I listed the project in the Rye and
we work in the medical image analysis
and what I'm showing here is the tool
that we built which is a tool that is
used by radiation oncologists during the
during cancer treatment planning so what
happens in cancer treatment planning is
that a trained physician the radiation
oncologist would have to look at a 3d
medical image of a patient so we're
looking at a typical computer tomography
scan that they would take and they would
go through every slice of it image and
they would accurately delineate all the
organs that are interested to them the
organs that have the tumor but also the
organs that need to be spared in the
treatment because eventually you know
they're those delineations will go into
into this radiation therapy machine
which effectively needs to focus a
high-energy beam of ionizing radiation
of the tumor and try to you know have a
shrink or destroy it for the same time
it needs to spare everything that's
around the tumor so what they do right
now they would basically go through
every slice and they would do something
like that they would say that you know
I'm trying to contour blender here right
and you know on this slice I'm gonna
draw a contour like that and by the way
you may notice that I'm using this
surface to do in a pen which they don't
have so they would use the mouse and a
keyboard right and they would then
switch to the next slice and then they
would draw another contour here and then
they would switch to another slice which
gets pretty laborious and takes a lot of
time there are tools in the market to
improve this person but we believe that
we have built something that could be
cool of them to be even more efficient
so we have this fancy button here that
says our structure set and when I
when I click on it I have this selection
of organs that I'm telling my algorithm
to look for so I'm pressing start and
what happens right now is machine
learning algorithm is running in the
background going through every single
box so in this image trying to classify
it tell whatever this voxel is belongs
to a bladder or two a prostate or two
left femur at the right femur and it is
pretty efficient so you know this
machine here it has an i7 CPU a mobile
CPU and it takes a total under a minute
to come up with a segmentation so now
here we have the full segmentation of a
prostate CT scan so it's not 100%
accurate but we have all the organs in
there and all the contours are very
precise and all that they have left
they're all that there is left to do is
for example here where we have the
prostate leather interface probably
didn't get it right I would click you
know the add/remove and I will clean up
those pieces of prostate segmentation
that went into here and you know running
contouring hundred in the ten slices
right you would have to go for probably
10 and fix them up and the rest and that
gets you it gets you there also in this
tool we have this nice volume renderer
which helps you visualize you know
what's what's in there in 3d yeah so
this is it this is project in right
there are a lot of things that we plan
to do a lot of things that you can do is
a machine learning based image medical
image analysis so and we're working with
other regions and other problems in the
radiation oncology and radiology alike
so for now this tool is available to
select clinical institutions but if you
are one of them and if you're
curious to help us and participate in
this program and get your hands on this
tool please contact us project in Rye
and thanks for your attention